what are your uh thoughts on
the spiritual aspects of life do you
think we have an inherent purpose when
we're
born okay let's deal with this because
there's three questions so what do you
think
on spiritual aspects of life listen
there's
there's thousands of religions out there
and they all think that the right one
and everybody else is wrong
okay so that says a lot right there the
the the whole point of mental point of
origin is to put yourself
first and you can be spiritually
you can just be like you know whatever
you want to call it but
i'm just going to call it putting
yourself first so that's what my thought
is on the spiritual aspects of
life the next part is do you think we
have an inherent purpose
when we're born i'm going to say no
i don't know there's probably good
people are going to be you know totally
against that but who cares
it's it's my show i can say whatever the
[ __ ] i want um no
i feel like you're you're gonna figure
out what your purpose is
as you kind of navigate through life and
i've said this before it's like taking a
frying pan to the forehead you're not
gonna
you're not gonna expect it you know like
i never thought that i would be doing
this when i was 20
years old never never i was riding
motorcycles and smashing like that was
that's what i was doing like that's all
that i cared about going to the gym
riding motorcycles and smashing
that was it i didn't i didn't care about
anything else
i didn't think about you know like is
this my purpose what is my purpose how
do i find my purpose where do i get my
purpose sort of thing
you know was i born with it i think that
you'll just stumble into it and then
when you do then you'll know that that's
what it is
that's that's really the only way that i
can describe it how do you distinguish
your thoughts
from the herd or internet programming by
not paying attention to the herd or
internet program is quite simple
cancel cable don't watch the [ __ ]
news
don't listen to any propaganda both
sides have
have an agenda all sides have an agenda
okay
they're they're they're trying to
they're trying to get you to do
what it is that they think is the way
that you should be going about things
and what you should be doing is asking
yourself is this good for me
does this let me put myself first
am i making myself my own mental point
of origin
when i think about this i'm going to
leave the ticker running on the show
guys
get on my email list i'm terrible with
emails
i will only ever send you emails if it's
something useful
i'm going to start releasing some of my
premium content behind the paywall
publicly for free to my email
subscribers
so i invite you to get on that i'll also
let you know if i have anything
important
that's available uh that you might want
to consider checking out
so i'll leave that ticker there on the
bottom for it for the show
i know it's going to bother some people
there's always going to be a comment
later on oh the ticker on the bottom
bothers me it was really annoying
shut up
you